tee
noo noo ん
皆さん
夢
お持ちでさん
うんという方もいらっしゃいますまぁちょっとでも夢っていうと大きな感じなのでもう
少し小さい感じで目標っていうところですよね
みなさんいろんな不況を持っていると思うんですね例えばまあすごい身近に1000席
取りたいと言うのもあればまあいい大学に入りたいあればいい会社になりたいあるいは
何か作り上げたい
いろんな目標からっ
でその目標
実現しようと思うともちろん熱い思い
これが一番館もちろんそうなんですね
でもですねなかなかその思いだけで届かないってば
私もこの後そういった例を示しますが
そういった時にちゃーどうしようかっ
いうので今日ご紹介したのがじゃあその夢とか目標を実現するためのアプローチ
つ
こちらのお話ですねそこで紹介したのが
システムは汽笛なんかちょっとギャップがあるなぁという感じかもしれませんがこの
システムアーキテクトという考え方を今日は皆さんに紹介しちゃいます
先ほど夢ということをいいますけど私の夢は実は何買ったかといいますと
宇宙にですね
宇宙から地球を見たいっ
1文字ねなんかこうみの前に全体額を地球にん
なっているというのですねボーっと見たいっていう意味だったんですね
まあなんで方とみたいと思ったのかわからないですが実は中学2年生の時ですね
友達と話してる時にふと宇宙に行って地球コート中日からどうなんだろう
行ってみたいな表の膝がはじめなんです
ね宇宙に行ってそうしようと思った時にまあいろいろ考えたですね
その時にはそうか宇宙のものを作れば宇宙に行ってメンテナンスしなきゃいけない
だったらウチの物作り人間になればいけるんじゃないかとまぁ
中学校2年生ですからね
考えたした今から考えるとウンナンですんだろうと思ったかなと思いますがそういう
思いを持ちます
で行って言っている家ですね
でも人が宇宙に行くには人が飲む中世作んなきゃいけない
相談抽選作ろういう風に考えられます
で仕事でまぁ宇宙開発の方に携わるようになったんですがすごく運がいいことにですね
残念ながらあの
友人の宇宙船ではないですが無人の宇宙船を作ると
いう機会を得ることができます
それがこのここにまあ写真をしたら出ていますコーンとりっ
5人の抽選です
このコウノトリこの鳥っていうのですねあの6人で
まあ食料だとか水ですとか実験機これを受注聖書に運ぶための宇宙船なんですね
まあ会社によってこれに出すあることができまして
このコールと言っているサマー
大きさがけっこうありまして
重さが16.5とっ
これは円筒形なんですがちょっと映画4.4m
長さが約10m くらい大きさになります
これを宇宙に持っていっ中世車に荷物ん
ということを返します
これがですねまぁどういうふうに使われているかといいますと
種子島からまあ持ちの打ち上げられですね
でそうするとですねだいたい秒速で7.9 k ぐらいの速度で飛んでいきます
脱 q 1周が90分ぐらいそこです
それでグルグルグルグル高速で回りながら徐々に重要に宇宙生者につかず
今ちょうど写真に出てますのは
宇宙戦車のした10メートルぐらいのとこで止まっているも相対的です
そう快適に留まっている実際は今日スプラトゥーン球目で飛んでるんですが
相対的に良いと思ってる状態です
ここまで持っていったですね宇宙講師にちょっとお手伝いいただいて
実際にはこのロボットああん
を使って4使うでも
つかんでもらったものを中聖書にくっつける
空けるとつながったところにハッチというと上がりまして
そのドアを開けてそこから荷物を運び出し様
何
で私はまあこれの立ち上げのところですねまぁ最初の設計でから去ることができます
私にとってはもうその時の目標はこのコウノトリを実現する
この鳥でミッションを成功させるというものにする
私はその開発の担当だったんですが
もちろん熱い思いをもってそれをやろうとしたんですが
私が何も言わなきゃっ
いいますと実はたった2つまあもう
を受けてサーブじゃないですねまぁ大阪にですねほんとに立った2つこれさえ満たせば
いいというものを実現するだけなんです
なんですがまあこれを実現してなんですよね
自分の会社の人たちがじゃあどんなコンピュータをするのか
どんなソフトウェア作ればいいか
このコウノトリは中身をどんな感じで作ったけど実現できるかというのは私は考える
やるなるんだったんですがそのたった二つの要求というものが一つ目は安全です
前に大勢ですねあの宇宙飛行士が宇宙船に乗ってますから安全では一番大切です
で2つ目もちろん
確実なミッションを実施
たった2つのことを実現数
という私がはやっぱりだったんですがそれがですね
どうやったら実現でいうか分からない
実はこの要求を持って
宇宙ステーションに6人の美人9 b 9の飛ばした
人っていうのは世界中誰もいなかっ
なのでいろんな人に今までの衛星の設計の情報ですがその聞いたんですけど聞いたん
ですけど
やっぱり違うのでもちろんすごく参考になるんですけど使えないんですよね
どぉすればいいんだろう
どうやったら自分はこのたった二つの要求を実現できるんだろう
それにすごくなります
でそれより悩みに悩み実は3ヶ月買う
まあそれをするとにつけたけどどうやったらそれが実現できるかどういうふうに考えて
いくとそれが実現できる
結果を出せるのかと実はその考え方を考えるに参加で作ります
まあ良くも会社は我慢して大変ですよし3カ月間
output ゼロでさつきっ
そんな状態でまぁちょっと考えてまあなんとか3ヶ月後くらいですね
こういう考え方でこのフォーマットメディクとできるはずだというとこまでといたし
ます
2項ちょっとを考えている最中にまあ他社の地図はドイツの方に中山に行けということ
で2年間ほどいて打ったんですが
でこの考えてアプローチ考え方を同僚の方とシェアしました
実際は同僚がまあそれを続け手伝ってくれて
パックのコウノトリというものが実際に出来上がったということです
デジそこの本当の仲だけができたわけじゃない
それを運用するための地上設備ですねこれ皆さんから向かって左下ですよね地上設備で
そこで運用する人が続きます
一方で上の方にはですねあの宇宙飛行士なぁ
宇宙聖書にいるんですが彼らに何をやってもらう
そういうことも含めて検討ができるのです
結果としてはことができたんですが
何をやったかというと
曲どんな振る舞え
のかその振る舞いコーンとに馬ですねこのというばようじゃどんな機能の組み合わせ
実現したけれど
じゃあそもそもその日の個別個別の機能というのは何で
どんな手段ですね
実はたったこれだけですたったこれだけを考えればいいということがわからないですね
そこでまぁ3ヶ月から宿泊した
じゃあちょっとこれを校庭の姉であるですねすっごい大変なので
違うカレーをご紹介しますすごい単純ある
ついお皿を誇示するための道具を実現してくださいこの鳥2つの要求これパリっ子だけ
です
この1個だけを実現するとちょっと見てみたい
まあ皆さん多分こう言われるとあーなんとなくあれこれというイメージが行う
の実際ありますなので私が役者そうなんです
実際にあるものをいっぱい聞いて想像できないかと思っ
実際このというときな3年ながら同じようなものはなかったので想像できなかったん
ですがちょっとそれを今あるものを忘れていただきていてはこれどうやったらですけど
そう
まあ
ついお皿を誇示するてはどういうことだの考えています
これはどういうことかというとお皿を
つかむと後は負担にするか
この2つが同時になったてもできるんですね
じゃあこのおさらばさむってのはどうすればいいかというと上から押さえると下から
支える
が実現できる
じゃあ上から笹をさえしたからされそうじゃないかというと上から指を受けてと滑る音
を下から支えている
滑るを飛ぶということが出来れば実現できます
じゃあこれ何で実現しましょういうことを考えるんですね
実際こんな商品がいっぱいですちょっとよらから探していました
実際はこういったものですねこれ
5分
ゴムでできているのでラン別はボムという素材実践主です
で上の方の丸いところに親指を起こせることによって
まあこれを支えることである使うことができて
したのですね下の方のなんか長細いバルーン心には4本で日はい
こういったものですね
これを実際にはこういうふうに保つということでちょっと実物
しちゃうんですけど
これなんですこんな散っちゃう
こんなちっちゃいものでとやるかといいますとせっかくなんでちょっとお皿もうて切れ
ました
あちゅぱ音のでもお疲れですもうこんなかです
ですよねなのでこういうふうに考えていくとまぁ今まで振って仲井真出なかったものを
示唆
考えることができます
いうことですねで実際立ったこんなものと同じように訪問とに同じように考えるんです
それでできるんですね
で
実際予定が何か区とまぁ今回ので言うと
振る舞いと機能と実現手段
これも明日になればで見つかったでバラバラの考え方を考えてあげてそれを重ね合わせ
ていっこい
そうすると一つの
実現したくらいですよ
いうことになりますん
じゃあそれを
実際こういうものづくりだけでやってもつまんないので
違うのでできないというのは我々絶対できました
実際会ってくるですねいろんなことに使えるということが分かりました
例えばこれこいつはまちづくりのでんです
で町樋の
スローリサーチと思っ
じゃあ街はみんな観点で考えたけれどもあまり先に達してい
実際これはあの後前石巻の復興に震災後にどんな町を作ろうかというのを現地のしたん
ですがあれは npo 私たち
は我々が言われるちんて行ったアクティビティなんですが
実際にへ今みたいな感じで
今回はこれは3つの視点で8役割実写
つまりどんな価値を持つま沈丁花
その価値を実現するにはどんな役割がどんな感じで組み合わさっていくことができる
じゃあその一個一個の役割は誰が担うのか
いうことを考えいうことをみんなで目指しますちょっと受かって右下のた日だしですね
ふたりのした能見はその結果が出てるんですがこれあのまっすぐのワークショップて
よくありますよね
多くのは続くのワークショップはマージンが何をやるのかというとこに行こうとしても
定期月をもって書こうとしていくということが大好きもちろんすごく大切です
一方でこれ我々のちょっと何が違うかというとですね
街全体としてじゃあどんな価値を提供する
その価値のじゃあどうやってどういった役割のコンビネーション
関係性であるかというふうに全体を決めていく
その全敗のなかでの自分というものを決めていくというところはちょっと違う
アプローチがあります
パコヘまちづくりので例ですがちょっとものぞくに近いところがあります
じゃあも全然違うとこ行ってみましょう
思考がん
我々も最近イノベーション創出のアクティビティをよくあるんですが
これはですねデートしていの生地に考えるという思考の流れを開けて着てみたい
つまり目標としてはイノベーティブに考えということです
どうですかなんか全然違いますこんなことにも使えですね
実際にはコレなにがでるかというとじゃあその時にどんなイノベーティブに考えたいの
かというまず目標生
目的を設定します
その目的を満たすためにじゃあどんな思考の流れをやるかというのでここは方法論に
なってますが
イノベーティブに考える場合はよくいう思考発散と収束の繰り返しです
これ今回はすごく単純な発散収束発散収束という
すごくたんじゃねぇで行っていますが実際8さあカツさん収束収束でもいいわけです
収束スタッフのバザー
ハッサン手足ってゆーぽん流れをデザインした国じゃあ
それぞれのハッサン収束をどんな手法である
8歳で8日ラヴレースをですね皆さんこの
ねここではブレーンストーミング最初はさして c まず方というので収束をしてその
後強制連荘マトリックス方というのを使って発散して最後はの旧コンセプト
セレクションと首相が目指すので収束するという中でございます
つまり自分たちがある目的
向かってイノベーティブに考えるためにどんな風に流れを施工のラベルを作ってここれ
をデザインしちゃって
こんなんでも使えるわけですで我々になってるです
もう
本当に何にでも使えますなんか目標設定してあげるとその目標に向かって
ああどんな視点で考えるのはに入るかな
でそれぞれの視点で考えたものをどうやって組み合わせればいいかと
これをやるだけでほとんどのケースがデザインする分
つまり何か目標があります
それぞれの視点で考えたりと
それらを重ね合わせることによって最初の目標到達するそうしてあげるとそれぞれ
その前のが見たい
どういうして何をやればいい立っての明確になりますから
今度は例えばそれを次の目標に設定するちょっとちっちゃいわけですね
そこに向かっていくということをやるとすごく大きなまあゴールに向かって向かうとき
に
ちょっとちっちゃい目標を設定してじゃあこのひとつの目標
ドアで効果というところでもう一度同じことを繰り返すするのでどんどん実現できる
最後ですねじゃあ私のこれを適用したすごく小さいで4
ご紹介しますあまり食べたことないですけどこれですね
私先ほど言った通り宇宙に行って地区みたいんですそれが夢なんですという話をします
もちろん宇宙に行く一番まあ今ほとんど日本では唯一の道は宇宙飛行士になるんですね
なので私もそれを記事ですね宇宙飛行士になろうと思って2回ここを2回ですねここ2
回の応募にさを押しました
もちろんですね残念ながら落ちたのでここでか皆さんに違う役割として喋ってるのは
受かったダム私宇宙飛行士の話をしてるんですが全然違う話をしますが
ですね自作の打越の応募まあ募集出した方いらっしゃいますかね結構いろんなことを
書かなきゃいけない
here それだからいいのかなぁ強く自分は持っなんかといいますと
ます
宇宙飛行士実際募集のたびに多分ですね欲しい人材が違うじゃないかなと
どんなちー講師を今市長としてたしの考えます
で一方で自分の経験ってありますよね自分の定点能力であるわけですから
じゃあ自分は何を経験して言って何ができるか0
でもそれを主張できるのは
神なんです
募集要項ですねここにどうやって落とし込んでいたですね
なのでまず最初どんな中古し得るかなぁと考えてあげてそこと自分の経験
何をうまく
重ねをしてあげると自分はこの経験はこの能力は今必要な宇宙飛行士の能力とマッチし
てます
you
これを考えるんですん
でその後うん
じゃあ自分もこの経典能力というのは
この後主力はここにないといったよええ
こういうことをかけて言ってるとこに書いてあるというところまマッチングするわけ
です
そうすると自分は宇宙飛行士になるための
まあ今一されているものを持ってますよという書類が作れる
実際に2回目ですともうこれからなんですかね
ゆうステーションが終わりに近づいていく2008年募集なんですが
2008年時の募集なのでこれから終わりに近づいていくというときにじゃあまだ宇宙
ステーションの募集をしていると
という言葉
短期で宇宙飛行士を養成しなきゃいけないと
なので短期で要請できる宇宙飛行士でもちろん宇宙ステーションに滞在するとことは
夫妻製の板からいろんな人たちと共同生活
じゃあこれをいかに自分ができる人間かということを示さないといけないので私は
たまたまこの通りやってましたので
方の鳥のやってきたことを最大に無視してですねあのほんとなことや何なことでば自分
はこれはこんなに組んで少なくとも行けます
いう情報で詰め込まれるでこの時にですね欠点を書くところもあるん
欠点もですね違う観点から看取り店にいくらで売れている理由
頑固であるいやこれは粘り強いとも言えるところです
一波でもう企画なのでそういったことをうまく埋め込んでいってこの子しおこ尽くして
いく
これってもう本当にすごい身近じゃないですか皆さんが普段やったようなことにいくら
でも多い聞くこれがこんなことを作るパックところからコウノトリの全体を設計する
ところでこれが共通的な考え方で使えるです
今日みなさんにご紹介したのはこういった何かゴール
実現したいことがあるときにそれに向かって行く時にちゃどういう風にすればいいん
もちろん一番大切なのはための熱い思い
でも熱い想いだけではなかなか行けない
そういった時に役に立つこの指を実現するアプローチつ
これとしてしても飽きてきているというのを皆さんに紹介しました
ぜひ皆さんもですね自分の夢目標の実現のためにこのシステムは使ってみてください
どうもありがとうございます